il est branché old school et raille le
bitume réunionnais sur son longboard
michael alias night membres du tak arai
d'écrou une bande de riders du sud nous
entraîne dans une de ces descentes
préféré sur route
ça se passe dans le sud de l'île
je m'appelle michael knight de mon
surnom et je fais du longboard depuis à
peu près
depuis à peu près deux ans le board of
school chez patty duke route à kari des
aussi fois qu'on est à peu près que deux
à faire du old school sinon les autres
ont pu s'orienter sur du skate de
descente on va dire
avec une planche comme ça on peut faire
des carabines super agréable et puis le
fait d'enchaîner plein de petites
manoeuvres des grosses têtes sur la
planche peut faire des petits tours sur
soi même ou les un petit peu en arrière
passer des switchs voilà tout ce genre
de figure qu'en fait
moi je roule à se desserrer aussi pareil
pour bien pour faire des cures de bien
ample voilà pour enchaîner les
manoeuvres plus facilement la route et
par mais ya pas une voiture mais sinon
habituellement quand on roule sur des
spots sur des spots ouvert là on allait
on a les taux qui tout ça mais pareil on
choisit nozer j'ai pas trop de
circulation soit c'est de bonne heure le
matin
ou alors en fin d'après-midi quand il
fait pas trop chaud on choisit toujours
des moments où il n'y a pas trop de
circulation est plus pareil et toujours
avec les talkie walkie mais là c'est
l'idéal
après deux voitures c'est le seul top
oui
ça commence par de la pente douce pour
le soul c'est tout ce qu'il faut pas
trop de pente justement pour pouvoir
enchaîner des manoeuvres des crocs step
marché un peu sur la planche faire des
petites rotations tout ça après ça se
corse fort au cirad freiné assez freiné
en quarts
ces tarifs des cartes beaucoup plus
appuyé faire déraper aller un peu les
roues bah justement pour freiner sa
vitesse parce que des planches comme ça
s'est passé pas non plus des planches de
descente ça s'emballe si à trop de
vitesse la souplesse de la planche et
puis les réglages des trucs qui sont
hyper soupe la c'est sa part sa part
n'importe comment
donc faut garder une allure assez
réduite on va dire pour pouvoir faire du
old school